[موسيقى]
ما عليكم هذا اللي كان ممكن يصير فيي لو
استجبت للعوائق المجتمعيه
والصور النمطيه لكن بحكي لكم اني انا وصلت
لوجهتين
واخذ اس تلقي
مرحبا جميعا كيف حالكم
انا ليث ابو طالب عمري 28 سنه من مواليد
عمان الاردن وتنقلت حول اكثر من 70 مدينه
حول العالم تجربه كتير حلوه كتير ناس
بتسافر لتسترخي وتسترجم وتستكشف مكان جديد
وهذا اشي كتير حلو بس اللي بيميزني انه
انا بسافر لاسترخي لاستجم لاتعرف على مكان
جديد وبنفس الوقت لعامل اثر مجتمعي لاحسد
الشباب لنعمل انشطه تطوعيه لنسبك في مع
مختلف المبادرات والمنظمات وهذا هو الاشي
اللي بيميزني في السفر حول العالم
بال 2012 كنت توجيهي بمجتمع بينظر للصخر
نجاح او رسوبه بالتوجيهي كنجاح او فشل له
في الحياه كنت علمي مدرسه حكومه بكر اهلي
عندي اثنين اخوان اصغر مني فتخيلوا قديش
الضغط المكان موجود علي بدي اكون قدوه
لاخواني وبدي انجح من اول مره بالتوجيهي
ومن هون فعلا حطيت عقلي براسي درست ونجحت
من اول مره الحمد لله رب العالمين رجعت
على البيت ماما عمالها بتبكي وهي مبسوطه
بابا عماله بيعبطني وببارك لي خالاتي
وعماتي عمالهم بصغرتولي اكلنا كنافه
ورقصنا واحتفلنا وانبسطنا كتير وصراحه كان
انجاز كتير حلو بس ايش كان في عندي تاني
يوم حفله زميلي الثاني واليوم اللي بعده
حفله زميلي الثالث واليوم اللي بعده زميلي
الاخر كل حفله كنت عماله بروح عليها شعوري
بالانجاز وبالفرحه كان عماله بقل لانه
ايقنت احنا عملنا بنعيش بمجتمع عماله بقطر
طموحاتنا بالمراحل الحياتيه نجاحيب
التوجيهي حصولي على بكالوريوس بالجامعه
اني اتزوج يصير عندي طفل هاي مش انجزه
وانما مراحل حياتيه الاستاذ بنجاح برافو
لكن الشخص اللي بيفكر انه يطلع خارج
المالوف هذا هون الشخص اللي بيكون عماله
بينظر للنجاح بطريقه اخرى ومن هنا تغيرت
نظرتي للحياه بشكل كامل حكيت لنجاحي
بالتوجيهي هو مسنجح لالي وانما هو السياسي
لمرحله من الحياه فشو لازم انا اعمل ليكون
عنجد نجاح لما قدرة زي اليوم اوقف قدام
الناس احكي لهم انه انا انسان بعتبر حالي
ناجح واثق بنفسي عندي محتوى بقدر اوقف
قدام اي حدا لو اجا يحكي لي فاس بحكي له
لا جوجل ماي نيم حطوا اسمي على جوجل
وبتعرفوا شو اللي انا عملته مش وانما ثقه
بتعب السنوات الماضيه كامله اللي اشتغلنا
عليها لنقدر نوصلها لحد الان
وفعلا من هون كنت عمالي بحضر برنامج خواطر
لاحمد السقيري وكان عنوان الموسم بال 2012
التطوع فدخلت على الموقع الالكتروني الخاص
بهذا الموسم تعرفت على مجموعه من الشباب
والصبايا عملنا مع بعض اول مبادره تطوعيه
وكل نشاط كنا عمالنا بنعمله كنت الانجاز
خلف الكواليس كتير شغلات عم بتصير من
تنسيق متطوعين الحصول على دعم زي البصير
اليوم بالافيفن
كراسيكم جاهزه بس ما بتعرفوا قديش اخذنا
اكثر من سنه واحنا عملنا منسق وبنشتغل على
هيك وفعلا هون صرت عمالي بحثت انه انا في
عندي صار محتوى انا صرت
عمالي بشهرك بكثير من فعاليات عم تعطيني
هذا الشعور بالانجاز وبالنجاح الداخلي
كانت هاي الفتره اللي هي ما بين نهايه
التوجيه ودخول الجامعه دخلت الجامعه بتخصص
تقنيات حيويه زيناتو وراثه كنت متخيل انه
هيك راح الاقي مسرح جريمه وامسك شعرها سي
اس اي او محقق كونان بس للاسف ما كانت
تخصص بهاي الطريقه من هون حكيت
انا بنت لو ما طلع لي جامعه بنفس المحافظه
اللي انا ساكنه فيها يمكن اهلي ما خلوني
ادرس كتير بنفسي اشارك زيك بس انا ما بقدر
اروح على الشمال والجنوب انام بمخيم ثلاثه
ايام عشان انه انا اسقي المهاراتي انا لو
طلع لي انه اطلع اعمل مناظره بالبحرين زي
الفرصه اللي طلعت لك انا عندي الخبره انه
بقدر اعمل مناظره بس اهلي ما رح يخلوني
ليه لاني انا بنت وفعلا هاي الفكره ضلت
عمالها بتتكون براسي بشكل اكبر لحد ما انه
بلشت حكيت لازم نعمل شغله لنكسر الصور
النمطيه بمجتمعاتنا ونعطي فرص متكافئه
للكل بغض النظر عن النوع الاجتماعي ومن
هون اسست حركه هيفرسيه العربيه مش فقط في
الاردن في المنطقه العربيه كامله وهاي
كانت نقطه الانطلاقه شكرا
وهاي كانت نقطه الانطلاقه لالي لابد
مسيرتي مع هيئه الامم المتحده بديتها مع
هيئه الامم المتحده للمراه في الاردن
لاشتغل على حركه هيبوشي بشكل اكثر على
اهداف التنميه المستدامه لنحكي للناس
التعليم الجيد الحد من اوجه
العمل في النوع الاجتماعي القضاء على
الفقر القضاء على الجوع العمل المناخي
وغيرها كتير من الامور هي عباره عن حق
احنا لازم كلنا نشتغل على ليكون فعلا هذا
اشي حق لالنا واذا موجود عندي هذا الموضوع
مش معناها انه انا ما اطلع على الناس اللي
حوالي لازم دائما اخد خطوه لوراء اشوف
الصوره بشكل اوسع لاقدر انا اعمل اكثر
مجتمعي واساعد الناس وفعلا من هون اسسنا
حركه هيفر سي لتصير اول مبادره للامم
المتحده في المنطقه العربيه معنيه
بالمساواه في النوع الاجتماعي انطلقت من
الاردن صار في عنا في تونس في عمان
بلشنا نحكي مع ناس بالسعوديه بالبحرين
بالامارات بفلسطين بمصر بكثير من البلدان
وهذا الموضوع خلى الاردن على الخارطه
العالميه ويصير توصلنا مباشره مع المكتب
الرئيسي للامم المتحده ما بنسى لحظه الفخر
لما بتوصلني دعوه اني اروح على الاحتفال
السنوي لهي الامم المتحده وبس الملكه
رانيا واقفه على المسرح عمالها بتحكي خطاب
على المساواه لانه تم دعوه الملكه رانيا
لتكون جزء من هذا المؤتمر والممثله
الوحيده العربي شعور بالانجاز كان كتير
كبير بديته كفرد بس صار في عنا كتير
متطوعين ساعدونا ليكون هم عباره عن سند
وصوره كتير كبيره لتساعدنا انه دائما احنا
نمشي خطوه لقدام هذا الموضوع خلاني احكي
انا بدي اطلع من دائره الراحه تاعتي بدي
افكر خارج الصندوق لازم انا اصير اتعرف
على الثقافات المختلفه واجيبها لنطور
برامج نقدر من خلالها احنا ننافس عالميا
ومن هون الناس لما تسافر شو بتعمل بتدور
ايش الفندق اللي بدي انزل فيه شو اسعار
تيكتات الطيران كيف بدي اركب المواصلات
اروح من هون لهون انا بعمل بحث اخر شو هي
المنظمات المجتمعيه الموجوده في هاي
البلده شو هي الشبكات الشبابيه منهم
المتطوعين الموجودين هون وبيكون هاد بحث
عمالي بعمله قبل ما اسافر بتواصل معهم
عشان لما اسافر استجم استرخي اسبح اجرب
اكله جديد وبنفس الوقت اعمل انشطه تطوعيه
لنشرك الشباب واتعرف عن الشباب اللي بره
كيف هم عملهم بيعملوا اونصه تطوعيه ولما
ارجع البيت بعمل صناديق فنيه بتعلم الناس
شو هي الثقافات اللي تعلمتها من خلال
الفنون الورقيه الفن اللي انتم عملتوه قبل
البريك من خلال الصناديق هاي صرنا عملنا
بنعمل صندوق بيعبر على الاماكن التراثيه
عن التجارب السياحيه على الرموز المتميز
اي بلد على سبيل المثال هذا الصندوق اسمه
الفن لاجل الاردن باستخدام الصندوق بكون
انا قادر اعمل البتراء المدرج الروماني
جبل القلعه المها العربي السوداء فنجان
القهوه الساده وبالتالي بعد ما اخلص كل
شكل بالفنون الورقيه اللي بتساعدني على
تنميه تقيل مخ الايمن والايسر بعمل سكان
لكيو ار كود بدخلني على مدونه تفاعليه
فيها كافه التفاصيل هذا المعلم السياحي
اللي انا بشوفه شو هي البتراء مين بناها
وين موجوده كيف بقدر اوصل لها والاحلى
مجدي راح يحكي لنا عنه قبل تعاونا مع بعض
بهذا المشروع عملنا
تخيلوا ما احلى الشعور اني اكون لحالي
واقف بالبتره كامله تعودنا مع كتير زي
حكوميه دخلنا البتراء صورناها
عشان نعطي للناس فرصه انهم يشوفوا البتراء
اون لاين وندمج التكنولوجيا بالفنون
بتجارب الثقافيه وقيسوا على هذا الصندوق
المكسيك الفني لاجل كندا وغيرها من الامور
صرت اعمالي بنطنط من مكان لاخر عشر سنتين
بالمكسيك رجعت باخر اسبوع من رمضان متحمس
انه استقر بالاردن مره اخرى لنعمل نشاط
تاني بعد الخبره هاي اللي عشناها بالمكسيك
لمده سنتين ونطور شغلنا فيها هاي السلسله
اللي حكيت لكم اياها كامله ما كان الوصول
لالها سهل كانت هي عباره عن سلسله من
الاحداث بدات لما انا خليت هاي الوقعه
اللي هون مش انها تدمرني تكيت حالي ووقفت
ما خليت الصور النمطيه والعوائق المجتمعيه
تكون
اسم وسيل لان تسحبني لورا او تخليني مكاني
لا اعتبرتها هي عباره عن تحدي انه انا
عمالي هلا بطلع عن المالوف لانه لو كانت
الطريق سهله ايش معناها انا عمالي بعمل
اشي مقلوب دائما الاشي غير المالوف هو لما
الشخص يصير عماله بيمشي عكس التيار وبلشنا
هون عمالنا بنشتغل بشكل اكبر ونحاول ندمس
كل هاي الفنون وكل هاي التجارب بتجارب
مختلفه فاستسعد اول تطبيق للامم المتحده
معني بموضوع المساواه في النوع الاجتماعي
اسمه وي رايز بنستخدم مبدا التلعيب من اجل
التعليم ودمجناه في قضيه المساواه في
النوع الاجتماعي لنحاول نستهدف الفئه
العمريه الاصغر من خلال التكنولوجيا
التكنولوجيا مضره بس احنا ما بنقدر نلغيها
من حياتنا صح ولا لا لكن في هناك استخدام
ايجابي للتكنولوجيا ومن هون عملنا تطبيق
وي رايز وهاي النقطه اللي كانت لالي خلتني
اشتغل شغلي الحالي كمسؤول تعبئته تحريك
الشباب للمكتبه الاقليمي للامم المتحده في
البلاد العربيه بكل فخر بحكي انه انا
مسؤول عن الشباب للام م المتحده في كل من
الاردن مصر تونس المغرب فلسطين ولبنان
وانا عمري 28 سنه
زمان انه انا ادخل الامم المتحده ودائما
حاطه انا اللوجو بتاعهم كنت على الكمبيوتر
تاعي انه بحكي بقانون الجذب وهيك كنا نقرا
هاي الكتب زمان ايام الجامعه بحكي لنا انه
لما نضلنا نشوف ليش كثير هذا الموضوع ممكن
يجذبنا فقلت عمالي بعملها بس ما عمري كنت
عمالي بحلم انه انا ادخل الامم المتحده
كمستشار كانتر كمستشاره عالمي مسؤول عن
الشباب في هذه المنطقه فتخيلوا ما احلى
الشعور عمالي بشتغل اشي انا بحبه عمالي
بسافر من بلدان مختلفه لاعمل الشغل تاعي
لاحاول اتعرف على الشباب لاطور حلول
مختلفه ومن هون ومن هون بدات مسيرتي مع
الامم المتحده وهي جوله مشيت من لما انا
كسرت الصور النمطيه لاصير احاول اشوف
الحياه بطريقه ثانيه ما خليت البكالوريوس
تاعي وفكرتي انه انا رح اكون زي ستيس اي
انه في عندي مسرح جريمه وامسك سعرها تكون
عائق امامي بالعكس اكتشفت هذا الموضوع صار
يميزني لما اي حدا يسالني شلون عم تشتغل
بيفكروني شو درست بفكروني درست اشي له
علاقه بالتنميه
ميديا او اشي زي هيك بحكي لهم لا دار
الزينات ووراثه فدائما هذا بيكون الهوك
لاي شيء بعمله لاحقا اكيد عملت
عشان احاول اعزز موضوع التجارب العملي
بعملها لسه ملاقي الدعم يعني بصور
فيديوهات بقعد اسبوع اعمل عليها
حكيت لنا ساره وبالاخر بنشرها على
اليوتيوب بتجيب 100 لايك بس انا مامن انه
راح اوصل لمرحله من بيوم من الايام الاقي
الدعم اللي راح احاول انه يساعدني انه
يدعمني لا اقدر اكمل مسيرتي لانه صرت هلا
عمالي بعمل هاي الفيديوهات ونحطها على
اليوتيوب للتجارب الثقافيه اللي احنا
عملنا بنعملها حول العالم والله بدون
مبالغه رحت شفت اماكن بعيني لما اشوفها
احكي يا الله كيف هذا الاسم موجود على
الارض اظلني اصوره واحاول بدي اطلعه على
الكاميرا بنفس الطريقه اللي عيني شايفه
هذا الموضوع بس للاسف يعني هاي التجارب ما
بقدر انه يعيشها غير الشخص اللي بتمرد
تمرد ايجابي على المجتمع لياخد خطوه
ايجابيه للامام
حاولوا اكسروا الصور النمطيه الموجوده
حواليكم اطلبوا الدعم من الناس الموجوده
حواليكم ايضا شاركوا اندمجوا بالانشطه
اللي بتصير حواليكم اطلبوا المساعده اذا
حسيتوا حالكم احنا ضايعين وتسالوا عن
المساعده هذا اللي عملناه احنا ما
وساعدونا وغيرها كتير من الجهات وبحب احكي
لكم هاي الشنطه انا لما سافرت فيها كانت
كتير خفيفه والله كتير ثقيله
تغطيت فيها
كل الحواجز رجعت فيها بعد سبعين مدينه
بشغف بطاقه بحماس
فوزنها مش وزن الاشياء الموجوده جواها
وزنها هو بوزن المسؤوليه والتعب والايام
اللي انا وصلتها لحتى ما قدرت اوصل لهون
بحب احكي لكم انه انا هلا بكل فخر
حصلت على جائزه الملك عبد الله الثاني
المركز الاول
حصلت على جائزه الرياده الواعد من
درع الشكر لاول مبادره عملناها عن طريق
برنامج خواطر
دروع من جهات استضافتنا لتحاول تستثمر
بالطاقات بتاعتنا وبالاشياء اللي عملناها
[تصفيق]
من المكتب الاول المتحده لما عملنا
التقرير
من المكتب الرئيسي المتحده
وايضا هي فورسيلا للمرحله الاولى والثانيه
لما عملناهم بالاردن
دروع مختلفه وما راح اعدهم كلهم وازهقكم
افضل مشروع قيادي مستمعي
افضل قائد فريق احكي لكم هاي القصه تاعتهم
عن جد كانت كتير حلوه الهدا اول درع انا
بفوز فيه وبربحه بيكون في مسابقه اسمها
نحن قاده المجتمع وبكون فيها مسرين مسار
الشركه من انجاز ومسار الشركات المجتمعيه
فانا بكون مقدم للاثنين وبالصدفه الفكرتين
بتاهلوا للمرحله النهائيه فبقدم فيهم انهم
التنتين فبفوز فيهم التنتين بالمركز الاول
والله انه زملائي صاروا يحكوا فكروها انها
واسطه انه كيف انا بفوز بالمركزين بس لو
بواسطه الناس مش راح تكسب حالها لهالدرجه
فبطلع بحكوا بالفائز افضل مشروع قيادي
مجتمعي ليث ابو طالب بطلع على المسرح باخذ
الدرع تاعي برجع يا دوب بقعد والفائز
بالمركز ابو طالب باخد الدرع الثاني
الفيديو موجود على اليوتيوب وعلى فكره على
ما اعتقد كان ينجاز كتير حلو وبنفس الوقت
كتير دروع ثانيه
بحط هون دائما بعطوني شغف لما اكون انا
بحاله ياس كل ما احكي مع حالي لما لما
نحكي احنا هيك قصص يمكن تبين لكم انه
مشوار كثير سهل وهيك بس صدقوني كتير انصحب
بدموع بارهاق بمشاكل مع الاصحاب بس كل
الاصحاب بتقبلوا فكره فكره انك انت تكون
انسان مشغول بحياتك او انه انت عندك هدف
بدك تسعى له وبدك تمشي لاله فمن هون بعد
ما خلصت كل هاي الاشياء وبعد ما خلصت
التين مدينه السنه الماضيه حبيت اكافئ
حالي انا كتير بحبه فاهديت حالي رحله على
امريكا ورحت فيها على يونيفرسال استديو
رحت لعبت كل الالعاب وعملت كل التجارب
يونيفرسال استوديوز ايش لقيته هناك
الاوسكار
[تصفيق]
عمالي بحضر هاي المقابلات لما يطلع يوقفه
انا بشكره ماما وبشكره بابا على دعمكم
وبشكر كل اصحابي فهاي هي اصطبت تكون
عجبتكم شكرا
شكرا
[موسيقى]